good morning Hank it's Tuesday and I am
tired I don't mean just physically tired
although I am that I mean like
metaphysically tired I feel like my
brain and also my voice are kind of
limping to the finish line of 2017 this
is eventually gonna be a happy and
celebratory video but first I have to
tell you what's wrong with me some of it
is just my mental health problem too
much work and travel and not enough
sleep and exercise are bad for my OCD
but there are also larger forces at work
like lately I feel compelled to scroll
through my social media feeds for hours
on end even though the scrolling
generally makes me feel worse because of
my mental illness I've often felt like a
passenger in my own consciousness with
no sovereignty over the thoughts that
are called mine and lately scrolling
through the social internet I tend to
feel like a passenger in the larger
consciousness as if history isn't
something that we make together but
instead is something that's happening to
us James Joyce called history a
nightmare from which I'm trying to awake
and the history unfolding around us
these days does often feel like a
nightmare to me I don't know if this is
true for other people but I often feel
powerless in the face of injustice and
inequality and violence and also social
and political structures that don't just
allow for oppression but in some cases
actively encourage it I mean I'm just
one person and I tire easily and I feel
like I can't do anything except scroll
but that is a lie and this weekend I was
reminded that it's a lie when thousands
of people came together from all over
the world for the 11th annual project
for awesome which as I'm recording this
has raised almost two million dollars
for charity by the way you can still
donate until midnight tonight at
projectforawesome.com / donate where
there are still great perks available
including New Zealand nickels and
project for awesome socks and signed
copies of my book Turtles all the way
down and also at dftba.com you can get
this amazing project for awesome t-shirt
all proceeds go to charity but whether
you participated in the project for
awesome by donating or by making a
project for awesome video or by
commenting or by joining us in the
livestream thank you thank you for
reminding me that the social Internet is
not only about passive scrolling it's
also about hearing stories we wouldn't
otherwise hear and becoming better
informed and making deeper connections
with each other you reminded me that the
social Internet can be a platform for
activism and fundraising that truly does
make the world suck less and along the
way you reminded me of something else
it's not just that we as
individuals can change the world we are
changing the world every day each of us
through the choices we make the world
isn't somehow separate from our actions
and passions and beliefs the world is
made out of our actions and passions and
beliefs during the first half of the
project for awesome this year we raise
money for two great organizations Save
the Children and last mile health and
the CEO of last mile health Raj Punjabi
who grew up in Liberia shared with us
something his father often told him no
condition is permanent not the good
conditions and not the bad ones
inequality of access to health care and
educational opportunities are not
permanent conditions we know this
because we've seen dramatic reductions
around the world but political and
social stability also aren't permanent
conditions nor is peace or progress no
condition is permanent and while there
are big forces acting upon and within us
we are not mere passengers in history
the human story isn't something we're
scrolling through it's something we're
part of thanks for reminding me of that
Hank I'll see you on Friday